[CROWD NOISE]
OK, Anna Wintour?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
I know many people are
curious about who I am
and how I approach my work.
OK, off the table.
OK.
This is a class
for those who want
to understand my
leadership style
and then understand the
experiences that have helped me
become an effective leader.
Love that page-- triple,
triple thumbs up.
You need someone
who can push you
that isn't pulling you back.
I do not believe
in micromanaging.
It's important to
empower those that
are working with you
because you are nothing--
nothing without a good team.
It's really, really important
to surround yourself
with a team whose
opinions that you trust,
who are not in
any way frightened
of disagreeing with you.
And you have to listen.
Possibly the most important
meeting that we have
is the one that we have when we
all come back from the shows.
I would love for you to come
with us to one of these fashion
meetings.
There is always a
time when you know
you have to break the rules.
This cover was a deeply
controversial cover,
but Kim and Kanye were part of
the conversation of the day,
and for Vogue not to
recognize that would
have been a big misstep.
You are leading.
You are not following.
And that's a very
important lesson
to always keep in your mind.
You are driven by your heart,
you are driven by your talent,
and you're driven
by your instinct.
And if you start
to question and look
at what people are
doing to the left of you
or to the right of
you, you are going
to lose that clarity of thought.
Listen to the information.
In the end, it has to
come from who you are.
Own your decisions, and own who
you are, but without apology.
I'm Anna Wintour, and
this is my MasterClass.